The heroes of The Walking Dead are what drew
the majority of viewers to the show, but the
villainous Negan, as played by Jeffrey Dean
Morgan, quickly developed into one of the
most complex characters in the series.  Here's how.
Walking Dead viewers first meet Negan in the
season 6 finale, "Last Day On Earth," and
he makes a big first impression.
Not only do he and his faction known as the
Saviors capture Rick and his allies, but Negan
gleefully murders both Abraham and Glenn in
a pretty brutal manner.
He comes off as cold, conniving, and unspeakably
violent, leaving viewers to wonder, where
could someone so remorseless have come from?
Before leading the Saviors and swinging his
barbed-wire baseball bat around, Negan was
a pretty average guy.
As a kid in Virginia, he quickly gained a
reputation as a bully and troublemaker, but
that changed when he eventually met a woman
Lucille, portrayed on The Walking Dead by
Morgan's real-life spouse, Hilarie Burton-Morgan.
The two fell in love, married and hoped to
start a family, only for their situation to
quickly sour.
Losing his job as a gym teacher after a fight
at a local bar, Negan retreated into video
games for a while.
"Are you playing with children?"
"Uhhh… teenagers.
I think.
Mostly."
And at one point, he cheated on Lucille, and
to make matters worse, Lucille was diagnosed
with pancreatic cancer shortly before the
apocalypse began.
Negan does his best to provide her with medicine
in their now walker-infested world, but she
ultimately dies from her illness.
This drives Negan over the edge and he begins
tapping into his darker, more cynical side.
Sometime later, the Saviors form with him
as their leader, making him and Lucille — his
barbed wire baseball bat - a symbol of fear.
Negan has remained a constant presence on
The Walking Dead since his debut, arguably
becoming the most interesting part of the
program.
He even got his own flashback episode in season
10, aptly titled "Here's Negan," further exploring
his life, pre-apocalypse.
Of the series' main antagonists, Negan has
secured the most appearances, popping up in
over 40 episodes across three and a half seasons.
In addition, he has the longest lifespan of
the bunch, sticking around the land of the
living for roughly 60 installments.
His interactions with Alpha make him the first
bad guy to meet their successor, and him subsequently
killing her makes him the only main villain
to defeat another villain.
Perhaps most importantly, Negan is the sole
antagonist to turn a new leaf and become something
of a good guy.
Also worth mentioning is that Negan boasts
the highest kill count so far, with roughly
230 deaths credited to his actions.
Included in those deaths are six main cast
members.
In addition to Abraham, Glenn, and Alpha,
there's Spencer, Simon, and Beta.
One has to wonder if he has more records to
earn with his arc still unfinished.
Jeffrey Dean Morgan is an excellent Negan,
and he's made the now-iconic role all his own.
The image of him in his black leather jacket,
combat boots, slicked-back hair, flashing
a devious smile through his tight graying
beard is instantly recognizable.
It's impossible to imagine anyone other than
Morgan taking on the part, but that was very
nearly the case.
When Walking Dead artist Charlie Adlard created
the look of the character, he based Negan
on musician Henry Rollins, who auditioned
for the Negan role before Morgan gave it a swing.
Rollins spoke to Forbes in 2016 and discussed
the process, recalling the excitement online
about Negan's Walking Dead debut, saying,
"The internet was wild with speculation because,
in the upcoming season, they were going to
introduce the character.
[...] I went for the audition, and there were
five pages of really cool dialogue with all
these curses and it was beautiful, but I didn't
get it."
Rollins added that while many thought he should've
gotten the part, he was very impressed with
Jeffrey Dean Morgan's approach.
Rollins also wasn't the only big name who
vied for the Negan gig, as Scream's own Matthew
Lillard gave it a shot as well.
Despite, or perhaps because of, his terrifying
nature, Negan became one of the show's most popular characters.
So popular, in fact, that he's even managed
to cross over into unrelated video games on several occasions.
Arguably the most well-known appearance was
his guest spot in the 2015 fighting game Tekken
7, complete with his own unique fighting style,
moves, and a stage based on his TV introduction.
Need more Negan?
In December of 2019, both Negan and Michonne
were added to PlayerUnknown's Battlegrounds
Mobile for a limited time.
And if you're into Magic: The Gathering, Negan
was included as one of the new cards of the
controversial Walking Dead expansion.
For as beloved as Negan has become, it's worth
remembering that the character itself wasn't
conjured up out of thin air for television.
Negan first arrived in The Walking Dead #100,
surviving to see the series finale in issue #193.
Much like he does on the Walking Dead TV show,
the leader of the Saviors makes a grand entrance
with Lucille in hand, spouting expletives
and putting all of his enemies on notice.
As it turns out, Morgan took great care in
nailing Negan's brash yet collected personality.
"You do realize the storm of ---- I'm gonna
dump on Rick soon as I am clear of the ----storm
he dumped on me."
In February of 2016, Jeffrey Dean Morgan spoke
to Entertainment Weekly and detailed why pushing
the strong language envelope was so important,
regardless of how AMC felt, saying,
"We're going to push AMC — the plan is to
push them as far as they can because it's who Negan is.
[...] Negan is a guy that you want to keep
as true as possible, and that would be how
I want to play him as well."
Looking back on the cultural impact of Negan's
character, it's fair to say Morgan did just
that and then some.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about The Walking
Dead are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.